so for that reason i'm going to show you
this other way of solving the question
it is considerably longer and much more
inefficient but for me
um it does make sense because i'm like
okay without you know making this
logical leap
how else would we go about this what
other kind of tools do we have
at our disposal we're going to have to
take the scenic route
but it's going to work so let me show
you let's imagine we start back at the
beginning part c
how we go about proving this well i'm
going to
i'm going to prove this in much the same
way that you would prove many other
trigonometric identities which is
you're presented with a left-hand side
it's equal to a right-hand side
and you're told well what i want you to
do is to go from one to the other
start with the side that's more
complicated and see if you can simplify
it down
to get to something that is simpler so
when you look at the
left hand side and the right hand side
here which one looks to you
like it's more complicated and easier to
simplify to get to
the other side i think it's pretty
obvious that the right-hand side is more
complicated
the left-hand side is like the simple um
sort of version so what i'm going to do
is i want to take that right-hand side
you can see i've rewritten it again in
my sort of neater
more succinct c2 c4 c8 notation and then
i think about
well what can i do with this now you can
see why i've pre-written all this and
why it was a method i would like to
avoid
this is going to get messy right you've
got three
binomial factors here that are going to
multiply by each other
so it's going to get a lot messier
before it gets better so here's what
happens right
you can see what i've done on this first
line is i have just
done just a normal expansion this this
factor here
by this factor here you get a cos
squared cos theta times cos theta
you get a minus c4 cos theta from doing
that pairing here i'm doing first
last inside outside so that's what you
get from
these two factors here the cos theta
minus c8 that you've got from here
unchanged okay
that one wasn't so bad but now we have
to multiply something with
four terms by something with two terms
so in the end i'm going to get
eight terms this is going to be a little
bit terrible but
let's stay with it and see what we end
up with i get here's my
eight terms here i get this is
everything
in in the first set of brackets
everything multiplied by cos theta
you can see that's why this becomes cos
cube this is a cost squared and this is
a cos squared
and then you have this c2 c4 and a cos
theta hanging out the end
i rinse and repeat i do exactly the same
thing multiplying every term here but
instead of multiplying by cos theta
i'm multiplying by minus or negative c8
so that's that's what you get here
everything here has a ca on it as you
can see
okay so now what do i do with this how
do i tidy this up well i notice there's
a bunch of common factors here
right you can see here if i uh highlight
um there's a bunch of cos squared terms
right so i've got
these cos squared terms and then i've
also got this
cos squared term in here that's helpful
i also have a bunch of cos terms so
i've got cos theta here and then i've
also got some
cos thetas there so you can see i can
actually do a bit of
sort of collecting of these i can
factorize these terms
and i'll get something a little more
easy to work with so
here's what happens on the next line you
can see
this is me i might actually change its
color so you can see more clearly
this is me doing these red terms in here
that i highlighted above
they're from the cos squared
factorization
and then in here this is the blue part
so this is from the cos theta
factorization okay so
now the question becomes well how do i
deal with all
of this c2 c4 c8 and then i've also got
these um
this this weird sort of combination of
terms here now
when i look at these i think oh this has
to do
with sum and product of roots right i
wonder if your brain went to that part
of polynomials because you can see
here's um you know some roots one at a
time
and here are some roots three at a time
so
how do i get to using these sum and
product of roots results
in order to evaluate what c2 plus c4
plus c8 is to evaluate what this awkward
term is okay
what i've got to do is i've got to go
back to the last time i had a polynomial
that involved these um you know these
these c
c 2 c 4 and c 8 terms i actually have to
go back
a fair way i'm going to have to go all
the way back
where is it here we go to z to the 9
minus 1 which equals
this sort of disastrous mess now this is
the polynomial
i'm after right i can take this result
here i know what each of the roots are
and i also know because they're
conjugates that when i start to have
them interact with each other
a lot of stuff is going to cancel even
though it's going to look very much to
begin with because you know it's got
it's got 9 roots after all
so here's what i've got i'm going to
take that z to the nine
minus one that term there and what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to apply the sum of roots
to it right
now remember i know what all my roots
are the first one's one
i call them alpha beta gamma delta and
then there are the conjugates of
alpha beta gamma delta okay so therefore
the sum
of all of them just looks like this now
you might be wondering okay well if this
is the sum of the roots
where did this come from well for all
polynomials
the sum of roots is minus b on a that's
something you might remember
from quadratics but it's actually true
of cubics and quartics and quintix and
all of the rest even up to degree 9. now
the b that we're after is the
coefficient of z to the power of eight
but there is no z to the power of eight
term which is another way of saying the
coefficients are zero
and then the a you know what i'm doing
here is minus b
on a the a is the coefficient of z to
the power of nine it's the leading
coefficient so that's why i've written
it as 1.
okay so what i've got is this long
term expression here on the left-hand
side but as we've already seen in this
question
because you've got all these conjugates
all the imaginary parts are going to
cancel out with each other
which will bring me back to these cos 2
pi 9 cos 4 pi and 9 terms
that i'm after so let's see what happens
when i start to expand
or simplify i should say this when i add
alpha to its conjugate you just get the
real part of alpha but you get it twice
same thing with beta same with gamma
same with delta when you start to think
about
what are those real components it's
these cosine terms that i had before c2
c4 c8 i don't need to do c6 because
cos of 6 pi on 9 as we've already seen
in this question
is negative a half so that's that
simplifies out there
and this is marvelous because you can
see there's a positive one here
this is going to become negative 1 so in
fact
this just canceled out to c 2 c 2 plus 2
c 4 plus 2
c h so thankfully i can just divide
everything through by 2
and that gives me this result so that's
fantastic i can take
this and i can substitute it into c2
plus c4
plus c eight so that's what i'm going to
do i called this line
equation three so what i'm going to do
is take this
uh this result here c2 plus c4 plus c8
and i am going to substitute it into
line three which is
the main body of my proof okay so once i
do that this
is what you get you can see the c2 c4 i
should say c2
plus c4 plus c8 term which is the cos
square term it's just gone right it's
zero cos squared here
and i get left with all the rest of this
stuff which you can see from before
okay so now where do i go from here
right well i've got to deal with this
term in here this expression and also
this term along the end here now at this
point you need to pause and take another
deep breath right how am i going to come
with something that will help here
i could do the same a similar i can
employ some similar kind of logic
and try and think about the sum of roots
to this guy just like i did before
however when you take the sum of roots
two to time and three at a time and you
know in order to get a product of
all of these i'm somehow gonna have to
take the roots nine at a time
it's actually gonna it's still gonna
become quite messy so instead what i'm
gonna do
is i'm gonna use the result that we
proved in part b
my previous method for solving part c
was to start with part b and then go
i haven't used part b in this particular
solution method so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to call your mind back to
what we got from part
b this is just the result from part b
right um it's just stated as as was
required to be proven
and what i want to do is how do i
reshape
part b's result in order to get for
example i just think this one's easier
first
how do i get c2 c4 c8 out of this
like what could i do so that all the
rest of this stuff this z
squared this z this one i want all of
that just to vanish away
so that i just get c2 c4 c8 which are
already there on the right hand side
i want them to be the only things left
so a little bit this is a little bit
like if you're like sifting flour you're
like are you trying to pick the right
size
sieve so that you could just leave the
parts that you want the c2 the c4 and
the c8
okay what i want you to notice is look
really hard with this at this with me
right
just have a look at this first factor
you can see i've got this z squared here
and this plus one
and the only way to get rid of the plus
one is to somehow get rid of
the z-squared at the same time they're
just going to have to cancel each other
out
what value of z-squared would make it so
that the z-squared and the plus 1
would exactly cancel out well what i
want
is for z squared to equal negative 1
right if z squared were equal to
negative 1 then you'd have negative 1
plus 1 it would cancel what value of z
will do that well this calls you back to
the very first lesson in complex numbers
z squared equals negative one it's
solution it's the the sort of customary
solution we arrived at was
was our number i the square root the
principal square root
of negative one so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take
z equals i and i'm going to substitute
it in
so take a deep breath what have we done
here every time i saw z which is a bunch
of times on this line i've replaced it
with i
so you can see there's i to the 6 i
cubed that one hasn't changed
but then you've got these i squared
terms coming in here
which are going to cancel you can see
this i squared and this
plus one they're going to cancel each
other out this is the genius of it
right i'm also going to get you can see
on the left hand side
i know what ice to the power of 6 is and
i know what i cubed is these
real powers of i are very easy to
simplify
what do we get well you can see on the
next line i to the power of 6
is going to be i to the power 4 times i
squared and the reason i break it up
like that is because i to the power of 4
i the power of 4 is just 1 and we've
already pointed out i squared is equal
to
negative 1. so that's why i get this
negative 1 here you can employ some very
similar logic to get the minus i here
and then all of these terms here are
going to collapse right
negative one plus one it's all just
going to vanish away
so on the next line you can see what i
got here
this minus one is canceled with this
plus one that's a nice bonus
it leaves me with this minus i on the
left hand side when you have a look at
these terms in here
because the minus ones and the plus ones
that i've highlighted will cancel you
just get
minus 2c2i minus 2c4i
minus 8 i so you've got
negative 2 multiplied by itself three
times and then you've got
c2 c4 c8 so here's what happens when you
multiply the negative twos
by each other negative 8. you've also
got the i here so you've got i
cubed and so you can see this is going
to simplify
even further by dividing both sides
by i i squared or multiplying rather
the i squared out which gets that minus
out of the way and now i'm going to
divide both sides
by not just the i but also the 8.
so what have i got here you can see i
have arrived at a value for
c2 c4 c8 it's negative
and 8 which might look familiar from a
previous question we've tackled before
this is the product of cos 2 pi 9 cos 4
pi
9 cos 8 pi on 9. so in a moment i'm
going to substitute that into here
that'll just become minus uh minus
negative an 8.
but before i do that i notice i also
have this term
buzzing around here right c2 c4 plus c4
c8
how do i get rid of this well if you
think carefully
if you again choose an appropriate value
for z it's going to make everything
collapse on the left and the right hand
sides
in order to give me exactly this
combination of terms
so i'm going to ask you if you're if
you've been following along so far
pause the video at this moment and think
about what values of z might be
appropriate you could substitute into
our result from part b that would give
you exactly the coefficients that i'm
after cos 2 pi over 9 multiplied by cos
4.9
and all the other combinations if you've
already paused
pause it and come back or you're like my
brain is too fried to be able to do that
let me show you the value of z that will
be helpful it's going to be just
z equals one simple right what are you
going to get well
on the left hand side you've got uh you
remember z to the sixth
so the six z cubed and one so they all
become one
and then these terms uh become one so it
doesn't
cancel out as neatly as when i chose i
but you can see it's not too bad right
i've got three on the left hand side
i've got
twos appearing here on the right hand
side
and so i can factor out those those twos
out the
the front there you can see there's
there's three of them so 2 cubed
and that leaves me with when i do this
expansion this term here now or this
expression i should say i keep getting
that wrong
now this expression here should look
familiar
you've already done this expression or
you've done this expansion that led to
this expression because
this set of three factors is identical
to what we had let's see if we can find
it it's identical to what we had here
remember this instead of cos thetas
though i have something even simpler
these are just ones in the result that
i'm looking at so that's why
this result looks so familiar and that's
why it's also so useful to
us right so as i go further you can see
i am number one i'm gathering together
these terms here because
they're actually terms that i already
know the value of it's the same with
these terms only here and here i already
evaluated c2
c4 c8 just earlier on so i know that
it's equal to negative
and eight and i also know that this is
just equal to zero so it just
vanishes away so i'm really close now
right
you can see i've successfully gotten rid
of all my other cos 2 pi
9 cos 4 plus 9 terms all i have is these
paired up ones
so all i need to do is just simplify a
little bit and
make this expression the subject so
let's watch it happen
uh you can see here um that this is just
plus an eighth so one plus an eighth is
9 8. and then i just need to to get this
by itself i need to subtract 9 8
from both sides so just be careful with
your signs here because
three take away nine is negative six but
of course you can simplify that further
to be negative three quarters
so believe it or not we are pretty much
there i can go back to the last time i
was in the main body of my
argument which was this line here c4
right here so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to take
this it's the right hand side equals
this except
now i know what the value of this is
it's uh i think it's negative
three-quarters or three-quarters we'll
see down the bottom
and this guy here is just negative and
eighth so let's go down and do that
so i'm going to paste that in the
right-hand side
is that but it's equal to 8 times
cos cubed theta this we just
did the we just evaluated that so that's
negative three quarters
negative three quarters times
cos theta uh and then the along the end
here we've got minus and then this is
negative
and eighth and then i close my brackets
in fact i should draw those as big
square brackets so it's a bit clearer
like so okay this is looking promising
what have i got here well i'm actually
going to multiply through
by 8 because that's going to deal with
the fractions that i have here
that gives me 8 cos cubed out the front
when you multiply this by this the the
fours will cancel leaving you with a two
there
two times negative three is minus six
cos theta and then these two negatives
cancel and then eight
times an eighth is just going to be 1.
now we've proved this before when we
were first introduced to demarva's
theorem
this guy here is just the real component
of what happens when you expand out
cos theta plus i sine theta all cubed
this is the result
that you end up getting so therefore i
can say that this is actually equal to
2 lots of 4 cos cubed
minus 3 cos theta that's actually the
part that i was saying from pascal's
triangle from your binomial coefficients
and that therefore by definition or by
our proof of earlier on is
2 cos 3 theta it's the triple angle
result
plus 1 believe it or not that
is the required result because remember
it was on the left hand side of our
original equation we started on the
right hand side and miraculously
we've ended there so conclusion
uh this is a mountain of a problem and
uh i i don't know i don't think that the
authors of this question
intended for us to go this very very
long path to get there
but you can see without having made that
logical leap that we saw in our first
proof of
just taking the values that sit on the
unit circle this was a way that worked
and hopefully you were able to follow
the logic
it was mostly just the algebra that you
had to be very patient
and persevere with